how often did the two of you encounter
an independent filmmaker who's
intimidated by attorneys maybe they have
you know fears maybe they feel they're
going to be taken advantage of they
don't understand the process and what do
you do to alleviate those fears yeah it
happens a lot and I think the major fear
is cost you know oh we can hire we can't
talk to an attorney because we don't
have the money to pay for one and that's
such a misconception because typically
it's much less expensive if somebody
comes to us early on in the project
rather than later and asks us to fix
things because once they're in a
position where they really need an
attorney that's when it's gonna cost a
lot more money so we're constantly
alleviating people's fears that you know
it's okay and if you can't afford us
it's okay you don't have to retain us
and we have this wonderful book that is
a resource actually was just talking to
someone today who had who basically
asked me in about 30 seconds how do I
make a movie but he had a lot of
questions in there and I said you know
what you should really get this book I
said this is the book that's going to
tell you basically what you need to know
to make a movie and give you the
resources that you need to get it done
in terms of contracts and agreements
that you that you will need when you're
producing a film in fact one of the
things about this fourth edition is that
every contract in here that is discussed
with all the hints in the background and
the what to do if they disagree has
after it a an address where you can just
type in and download a clean copy of the
contract so you can change it and we
tell you how to use them it's it's very
user friendly and it is designed for
filmmakers who may not be ready
financially to hire a lawyer this this
book will get them started okay well
let's talk about what are some of the
things that may happen if first off
let's suppose they are scared of the
cost but the alternatives in on the back
end could be a lot more
costly what are some of those scenarios
if they did not have their ducks in a
row let's suppose one they the movies
ready it's ready to go to theaters
they've got a distributor if they vary
but I would say by the most common one
is not having signed agreements with
people which results in those people
having a valid copyright claim over
elements of the film so so many films
are done you know I know Anna I don't
know what their TVs hold hands and walk
into the sunset and also people are just
working for a day do I really need
someone to sign an agreement if they're
just working for a day but what happens
is anybody who holds a camera anybody
who has any sort of arguably creative
contribution to the film owns the
copyright to that contribution unless
there's a writing that says otherwise so
we get that work for hire language and
some things work for hire that means the
person who's hiring them actually owns a
copyright and if you don't have that you
can have a piece of the copyright
floating hunk over the plays with all
these different cameramen that you've
used and for as an example for the
proper person or the costume person all
these people are making contributions
which are copyrightable certainly if you
build a prop if you design a costume so
you really need to get little little
deal memos there's a form in the book
but you have to get you got to ever get
everybody to sign on otherwise the
producer who's paid for everything and
thought he or she owned the copyright
may only own a piece of the copyright
and that can get to be very very very
problematical get the written agreements
before you let people do work all in the
film and just tacking on to that you
know the real issue becomes delivery so
so many producers don't understand what
delivery is or even know what that word
is and that means you know when you have
a film you have to actually if it gets
sold you actually have to deliver it to
somebody and not only the film but all
the paperwork attendant to the film
because whoever's buying it wants to
know
you own all the copyright the chain of
title is clear all of these things that
we described in the book won't talk
about in the book but it's it's
interesting how people don't understand
that and once they go to deliver then
they have to backtrack and they're like
oh man I haven't talked to that person
in three years I'm never able to find
them and they have to do that and so it
just becomes a lot harder trying to do
things after the fact than doing things
as you go along I think just isn't
anything else in life so let's say I'm
doing a little indie short I'm paying
for it out of my own pocket I'm the
writer director producer I've hired a
gentleman or woman off of Craigslist to
be my camera person and I found some
actors I wouldn't need to worry about it
right and you're doing it at my house
I'd be fine correct no but that is
exactly the way people think about small
films and and and even worse all our
friends are getting together on Saturday
and we're going to make a short
typically no nothing signed hire
somebody off Craigslist typically you
would but it's amazing how many people
don't think a wit about these things and
then they sell the film and it's a night
mayor and expensive it's so easy to get
the proper releases at the time but to
go back later it's difficult and and
sometimes triggers a feeling that
perhaps they should receive some money a
feeling that they wouldn't have on
Saturday when we're all holding hands
and singing Kumbaya well forgive me for
asking this question but how often do
the two of you take a case that's maybe
a little bit too dare I say intimidating
or maybe too controversial you're asking
the wrong folks because it
those are like oh great what of example
two years ago the talk of Sundance was a
film little black and white film horror
film that was shot surreptitiously
at Disneyworld it was ever a talk of
talk of sundance every publication that
said anything about the film said isn't
it too bad it won't be released oh it
can't be released there are hundreds of
people in the background copyright
material trademarks logos they'll never
get it released so where did the film
land up in our office we worked with the
filmmaker a couple little tweaks and it
got released got insured that's what we
love to do yeah yeah we kind of I think
we're gonna thrive off of those
controversial it's not necessarily
controversial but I think it's more
where people have a preconceived idea of
what the law is and so much of that is
based on policy created by Studios that
doesn't necessarily apply to independent
filmmakers and so a lot of a lot of
issues that snow makers think are really
difficult I mean a very tangible example
is people wearing t-shirts with the logo
on it or a hat how many times where I
get the question of can we use that or I
have to blur this logo out absolutely
not you don't have to blur that logo out
you know you may want to because maybe
you want that brand to give you money
for product placement but legally you
have every right to use that trademark
in the manner in which it's intended and
you're even looking like really so
there's so many issues like that so I
don't want controversial I don't mean is
the right word but it's more just taking
these principles that people believe are
true and dispelling them of that yeah we
often talk about the worst censor in the
world which are the scissors in your
mind okay thinking some have these ideas
that they can't they shouldn't don't get
in trouble if they do and we work with
them so that they can be insured which
covers the issue of what happens if
somebody comes after us
and and film after film after film that
are really difficult I don't know if
your camera is picking it up but right
behind us is a poster for room 237
a third of that film was comprised of
clips from The Shining in a film that
the Kubrick estate would hate and they
did and they call and we deal with them
but did we have insurance in place and
all we ever did was organized a nice
disclaimer at the front which was
perfectly satisfactory to the filmmaker
in fact worked in the filmmakers favor
actually that was on the screen for a
long time and made the audience laugh
and and also set up the fact that you
know this this is how these professors
deconstruct the shining not the way the
Kubrick's deconstruct the shiny gosh we
have so many examples yeah there's a lot
like that and they are they're exciting
for us because we feel we opened the
door to filmmakers that they didn't know
could it be opened at all you know and
when we get that satisfaction from a
client it's so satisfying satisfying for
us you know to get that and to Furyk
line to go wow thank you it could have
never made this movie without you and I
don't think a lot of lawyers get that
yeah it's very blessed request the first
line on our website is helping artists
tell their story the their way and
that's what we're all about so when
somebody comes in as you say with us
care of it it's scary to maybe other
lawyers maybe scary to them we just
wring our hands and say oh let us jump
into this well we had a we had a great
one last can the talk of the of the
festival was a film called welcome to
New York it was a biopic about Dominique
strauss-kahn and his predilection for
New York Hotel maids told from the hotel
maid's point of view we couldn't talk to
her because she'd sign a confidentiality
agreement certainly Dominique
strauss-kahn wasn't going to talk to us
and his wife depicted by Jacqueline
Bisset
Dominique strauss-kahn was played by
George yeah yeah what you know it
people thought this had never get
released that not only got released it
was shown at the Cannes Film Festival
everybody was talking about it and we
actually in that case did not get any
phone calls in spite of scenes that were
made up between mr. and mrs. Kahn we
worked with the filmmaker on how to do
that so that it was being sharable
that's always the key for us can we get
the me you know insurance is that where
this safe harbor clause or I maybe I'm
you know distorting the meaning of it
but does that word this all comes into
play what comes into play on copyright
infringement questions okay with the
Dominique strauss-kahn example those are
personal rights very different area of
the law and in escape from tomorrow the
black and white horror film shot
surreptitiously at Disney World
you had personal rights of all the
people in the background you had a lot
of various fair use issues with
trademark and copyrights that were
present in the film so yeah don't
that one had everything right it was the
full basket talk about fair use and how
can fair use help save a filmmaker let's
just throw out a number six figures
hundred thousand or more in expenses on
their film and what is fair use go ahead
well let's start off with the question
what is very useful
which I think can succinctly being be
answered with the explanation that it's
really a person's right to use a limited
amount of copyrighted material without
permission from the copyright holder and
and that word limited I think is really
key and it also needs to be used for the
purpose of comment or criticism so
documentary films lend themselves to
fair use I think in every instance you
know you're doing a historical
documentary about anything you're going
to want to show clips or stills or
something that represents what you're
talking about
on so that's really what fair uses in a
very quick nutshell and then in terms of
saving clients money you know that's not
the purpose of fair use but it's
certainly a nice benefit but in terms of
when you're using fair use you don't
have to license and from the copyright
holder so that in and of itself means
you're going to be saving some money
people often come to us and say oh we
can't afford you we can't afford you but
we have a hundred thousand dollar budget
for licensing clips and so well let's
think that a little bit you know you
guys are our fees not nearly that much
and you can use things under your under
your right to use materials under fair
use although we can give you before you
leave an article from the New York Times
that showed talked about a film where we
say four hundred thousand so it just it
is an unintended consequence the purpose
of the Copyright Act which many people
don't realize is to encourage new works
so the creation of new works is a is a
is why we have copyright law and if it
helps the creation of new works that use
a little bits of other people's stuff
that is in furtherance of the copyright
law not in opposition to the copyright
law so does let's say five minutes of a
clip constitute copyright infringement
versus one minute
oh that's under the fair use time limit
or am i nothing to do with that I think
because the the the key is when the
documentary is are you using it
legitimately to illustrate some point
you're already making and do you use
what's reasonably appropriate and
sometimes that's a short bit and then
it's it's whatever it takes to but no
more than what it takes to illustrate
what you're trying to illustrate and
then is the connection clear so it isn't
a matter of seconds you take a
photograph it's going to be a hundred
percent you take a film it's going to it
is going to be
a small percentage but you can't put
just a percentage or a fixed number and
say that's it
filmmakers so often have a notion that
they you know 30 seconds or less is fine
or with the song six seconds or less is
fine and they come up with these with
these rules which are totally inaccurate
however courts do look at how much they
use that is certainly one of the factors
that courts look at is how much of the
underlying work do they use and that I
think goes part and parcel with another
factor that's extremely important with
fair use will it of how will it affect
the market so if you're going to
displace that market someone's going to
watch your movie instead of the movie
which you took a clip from that's gonna
weigh heavily that it's not very news if
it's not affecting that market and in so
many cases with documentary it's
actually helping the market you do a
film on the history of Asian Asian
American movies or something and you
show all these clips from Asian American
movies more people are gonna want to go
and see those movies so that weighs in
favor of the Farias argument but there's
not a hard-and-fast rule which again is
one of these notions that people think
there are let's take another position
let's say I'm a filmmaker who's had my
content taken and put in someone's film
and this other filmmaker is claiming
well it's fair use yeah who is this a
jury that determines how appropriate
that clip was let's suppose it was
something that I felt hey that was my
work and it's more than appropriate or
whatever the terminology you would used
earlier that to determine or to make a
point about something what what would I
do in that case let's suppose my works
been taken well theoretically the first
thing you do is really understand what
is and isn't fair use the book talks
about three different ways of answering
that question the statutory way the safe
harbor way which I just outlined to you
and then there's a best practices
booklet that also is relevant these are
different ways and you want to really be
sure that
no matter how you come at the question
you land up with the answer hey this is
not fair use then you go get a good
litigator or you might just call first
and see if you can work it out with a
filmmaker because so many many
filmmakers are willing to pay a
reasonable license and and you can tell
pretty quickly if they consulted with a
lawyer if they really had good guidance
or if they used it hoping you wouldn't
know and when you call they say up it's
fair use say you made a good example is
that it's you know music is is I think
an easy way to look at that music if
someone's using music is score for
creative purpose regardless of how short
it is even if it's three seconds well
always opine that's not fair use because
you're simply using it for the creative
value of it and because you'd like that
song if you're using music because
you're commenting on and you're talking
about a certain song by Elvis Presley
they'd be saying and you show a little
bit of that that's fair use but once you
start using that song as score
underneath the next talking head is in
your documentary that's no longer fair
use because you're using it just for the
creative purpose so you as as a
copyright holder who's had your stuff
infringed upon or used under fair use
would want to look at that are they
using it for the creative value of it or
are they using it because they're really
commenting on my work one of the
chapters in your book or one of the
sections I should say of clearance and
copyright everything you need to know
for film and television is entitled to
ask or not to ask that is the question
so what would that entail what is a
filmmaker asking as they are they asking
a copyright holder for permission yeah
and I think this again is one of those a
misconception people have that if they
do ask
they can't fare you something or if they
get a quote for something it affects
whether or not they can use something
under the under the fair use doctrine
and it really doesn't I think from a
risk risk perspective which I'll explain
in a little bit it can
a legal perspective if you're gonna go
out to the copyright holder and ask for
a license fee and as for how much it
would cost to license something and they
come back and it's an exorbitant amount
and you can't afford it you still can
fair use that material it doesn't affect
the fair use argument at all what it
does do though is it puts you on the
radar for that license holder and then
they'll follow up with you and say hey
are you gonna license that from us and
we sent you that quote and then you have
to have sort of an awkward conversation
of no we're actually using under fair
use now and they say no it's not fair
you it's absolutely not fair use you
have to license it from us and then they
come to us and they say well what should
we do and so it kind of it can create a
little bit of an uncomfortable situation
which I think all it really is it's not
a legal factor and also can create a
little more in legal fees because then
you're all of a sudden paying us or
someone else to negotiate with these
guys and sometimes in order to avoid a
dispute or to keep a good relationship
you will license something and maybe for
lesser fee saying this really is fair
use but we're happy to license it from
you but we're not gonna pay you what you
asked and so you enter into that
negotiation so you know to ask or not to
ask us a question we get a lot and
typically I'll say you know you
shouldn't ask and it's not because we're
trying to hide anything but it's because
the person who's licensing the footage
to you or whatever it is doesn't want to
have that conversation it's not in their
best interest and in order to elevate it
up to the lawyers who would be making
the decision on whether or not it's fair
use isn't really worth anybody's time do
you know what I mean so I usually say
don't ask unless there is a reason to
ask you know maybe there's a
relationship there
maybe you're you're delivering the film
to Paramount and you want to use a film
from a use a clip from a film that also
is owned by Paramount then you probably
should ask and have that discussion but
typically if it's just a run-of-the-mill
I want to use this news clip in my
documentary and it's clearly fair use it
would not go and ask for a license if
you know you're not going to license it
I'd also like to have it insurance in
place before you go asking
it just makes everything more
comfortable and if the price is very
high we talked about to the filmmakers
about different ways of sort of excusing
oneself from the conversation for as
long as possible without waiving the
fair use flag it's because especially at
the studios and the network's the person
that you talked to as a filmmaker has as
his or her sole job licensing clips and
their whole compensation their value to
the company is how much money did you
bring in licensing clip so they just
will you know the hairs on the back of
their neck will stand up when you start
talking about fair use well let's say
I'm a documentary filmmaker and I'm
making a film about let's say activism
in the 60s and I want to use a clip from
a folk singer and this folk singer is
still alive let's say would I just reach
out to their personal website and send a
nice email but already have this Eno
insurance policy in place and just play
nice first yeah well you may but you
also may not because you know my new
point and maybe I'm being lazy about it
but it's like who wants to have that
conversation if you don't really have an
intent to license it's sort of a waste
of every time in the sense it could be
considered kind of rude like why are you
calling me if you've not planning on
licensing this for me so unless you know
Michael's example is a perfect example
where there was a negotiation there they
had already thought maybe even agreed on
some terms then it makes sense from a
business standpoint to continue that
discussion and to let them know but you
just reach out to the folk singer when
you really have no intention of actually
licensing it I think is is
counterproductive you know it's just not
it's not necessary and it's a waste of
everybody's time in this case since I've
already mentioned what the film was
about the one of the producers and want
to maintain a relationship so it's makes
sense to call and have a courtesy call
say you know we've
he got turned down we worked on the film
to make sure everything came within fair
use they have insurance but I certainly
wanted you to know about it and they
they asked to see the film that's it's
fine you know when the opposite happens
as well where somebody does have an
intention to license most or all of
what's in their film and then they try
to license certain things and the
license doesn't work out for some reason
you know some say they won't license in
perpetuity and they have to end the
producers under an obligation to get all
licenses in perpetuity so then you have
the discussion I'm dealing with this
right now where I have a client who's
wanting to license everything one entity
has come back and said we can't give you
a license in perpetuity we can give it
to you for 30 years but it was an
exorbitant cost it was something about
three times what they were paying for
other archival material that was similar
and so she said how should I respond I
said get back to them and say you know
we can't license at that amount we're
happy to license it if you could meet
our hundred dollars a second rate that
we're doing with everybody else and if
not we're gonna have to pass on the
license and so we're dealing with that
now but that was kind of the converse of
what we were talking about before where
they really did intend to license
everything and then they're just running
into hurdles and if they can license it
great if not we're gonna use it under
fair use curious about but it's
interesting the way you phrase that they
say we'll just have to pass on the
license as opposed to we're going to use
it anyway a lot of and I think it's more
than just plain nice it's a
consideration for two things one is they
do own the copyright make a lot of money
and two very important the person you're
talking to at a studio has this very
narrow job of maximizing income from
licensing clips and and what you're
basically doing is is a threat to the
job certainly if it was very widespread
this person would not be able to bring
in as much money to the studio therefore
they wouldn't be making as much you know
it's a really very
I I and this goes for everything in life
every negotiation you ever have you want
to understand the other person's
position they're not being jerks they
just have this very narrow eight hour a
day five days a week job that they're
doing and they're not bad people they
just have very narrow limits very narrow
Authority they have a rate card and
their job is to get that rate on every
clip that's used of any material from
that studio that's their job that was my
next question was the tone of all the
correspondence because so many people
get excited when they see oh that's my
whatever and you know and then as you
said playing nice so the tone should
always be non accusatory for most of the
exchanges sounds like you're not
litigators and very often you know a
lawyer will call very bombastically and
you've got him upset client I don't
blame him for being upset you know I you
have to understand where they're coming
from and that makes it easy to solve the
problem he doesn't I also you know
that's our philosophy and the way we
work in this office is that we are
collegial and I think it makes our jobs
a lot easier we represent copyright
holders so we're not looking to screw
anybody over get something that's not
ours or you know anything like that and
so when we get that angry call we do
understand and it's not you know they
said for playing nice it's not playing
we really are nice because we certainly
understand and and I mean it's what
makes it makes our job easier and makes
it much easier to come to a resolution
people cuz we don't call them to screw
you it's fair use and you know sue us we
really after we get that call we respond
collegially with an educated response of
we understand you're upset but this is
the law that we've based our opinion on
and often times Michael likes to throw
in a copy of the book and throw in the
copy 150 page article that he wrote you
know we didn't just willy-nilly say fair
use on this like we really have basis on
on education and a study of the law and
a deep understanding of this area let's
talk about Eno insurance
what is you know insurance when does a
filmmaker need to begin the policy and
are there
times when a filmmaker will not need you
know insurance so you know insurance is
an insurance policy that filmmakers have
to get when their film is going to be
distributed in any way it stands for
errors and omissions and it covers
things like copyright infringement
trademark infringement personal rights
violations violations of rights of
publicity those things you can't touch
but which every filmmaker is susceptible
to if there is some sort of claim for
copyright infringement or something of
that nature
so that's what you know insurance covers
you for as to when you get you know it
really depends I think Michael will say
get it early all the time would you say
that well as early as you can as early
as you can I work on a lot of films that
are maybe so small or just very discrete
not controversial at all a feature film
that really is just shooting in one or
two locations where there the risk of
needing you know is very low and they
can wait until a little bit later if
they can get to for budgetary reasons if
you're dealing with the film it's a
little more controversial something
that's out in the open that is just
dealing with a controversial topic or
something of that nature then you should
get it a lot earlier especially if
you're doing something without
permission so if you're doing a life
story on somebody be them alive or
diseased and you don't have the rights
from that person you very well will want
to get you know early because what it
will do is if that state comes
afternoons is hey you don't have the
right to do this you got to shut down
production you have your insurance in
place and it gives you the won the
confidence but to a limit on your
financial liability to say yes we are
doing this it's appropriate for us to do
a life story right we have a First
Amendment right to tell the story and by
the way we have an insurance company
that's backing us up and so it really
depends on the project how early you
need to get it but as early as possible
as Michael said is always prudent so
even within the the final draft of the
script or maybe more when n't you're
about to start shooting some films we
recommend getting you know insurance
before the script is even done yeah I
think Dominique Strauss count
you mentioned before that was done very
early and that was a very high risk and
so they wanted to have insurance in
place early because if it leaked that
the script was being written
someone could potentially try to stop it
yeah they on that one absolutely at the
at the script stage in fact that was a
condition of one of the financial
backers that the filmmaker had to show
proof of insurance for you know smart
phone smart financiers in that case do
you have a list of carriers in your book
yes do you okay
great yes we have to have a list of
brokers brokers to be nuanced about it
we have a list of brokers and they kind
of go out to the same carriers that will
issue the policy we have a list of great
brokers that are very proficient with
independent film documentary films and
fair use and make the process very easy
and so it would be similar to getting a
car insurance quote in some sense they
would go through different things find
out things I visit and what I like to
tell but when Alan gee I like to use is
if somebody does approach you and says
you can't do this with my permission
before you have your Eno in place
that's a pre-existing condition so it
says if somebody goes to get medical
insurance and a heart condition the
carrier will say sure we'll cover you
for everything but that heart condition
and it's the same thing for film sure
will tell you for everything but a claim
from that person who's already come
forward and presented a potential
problem and if the filmmaker were to
conceal that there was a pre-existing
problem then that would be later on down
the line if something did happen so just
leverage no crime yeah interesting is
medical insurance you know if you just
if you don't disclose something on your
application that's fraud and they won't
it won't be obligated to cover you so
when filmmakers sit down to negotiate a
distribution deal for their movie what
happens who initiates it who speaks
first what points are typically brought
up
it happens in a lot of different ways
you know let's take a typical example we
just got back from Sundance
so we'll take a Sundance film that is
lucky enough to get distribution while
they're there there's interest from
buyers typically what happens is there's
a sales agent involved and that sales
agent will take the lead on the
negotiations and when we get involved is
serve at that same time but in a little
bit of a different role so simply put
the sales agent will negotiate the
material deal points what rights am I
getting how much money are they going to
pay me how long is the term going to be
and we will come in and make sure that
especially if we've been on since the
beginning and we really understand the
project just to make sure that there's
no rights that are being granted that
conflict with something that the
filmmaker has expressed to us before
your son's working on a music dock and
they want to retain the soundtrack
rights but the sales agent doesn't know
that and the sales agent gives away the
soundtrack rights and then it becomes a
big issue later on so it's good for us
to be involved at that early stage so
that we can make sure that the deal is
appropriate for the client and makes
sense and then we also come in again
running there's a longer form agreement
to negotiate we really start delving
into the into issues like delivery what
do they need to deliver you know deliver
the a delivery list that's attached to
your distribution agreement can be quite
onerous and quite expensive and if the
filmmaker isn't careful to go through
that and understand exactly what they
need to deliver could cost them tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
dollars to deliver a film and maybe
they're only getting in advance of fifty
thousand dollars it doesn't really make
a lot of sense so that's an important
thing that we make sure the filmmaker
understands everything we have to
deliver and going through that with them
and then again all of the terms in the
contract well would some of those items
be that they would need to deliver on
well most of them which are above my
head but technical ID is that they have
to deliver do they need to deliver a
35-millimeter print do they have to what
kind of digital format do they need how
much how many publicity stills do they
need to deliver do they need to deliver
artwork do they need to make their own
trailer you know there's all of those
issues that sometimes the producer just
assumes the studio is gonna do that and
sometimes they're not going to so it
really depends in other circumstances
they may want to it the stur say we're
doing this trailer we're not trusting
you to do the trailer were the marketing
experts but other times they want that
stuff to be delivered what are some of
the typical terms in a distribution
agreement whether it's theatrical or VOD
um so that depends you know I guess more
like I guess it doesn't really patent it
all distribution agreements you're gonna
have the term so how long are you giving
them the rights for and really we look
at that it's very dependent on money you
know if you're paying a lot of money for
this acquisition you're paying seven
million dollars for a film the acquirer
is going to get probably all the rights
and they're probably gonna get it in
perpetuity if someone isn't giving no
advance we might say okay we'll give you
broadcast rights let's say you're CNN
and you're giving a $50,000 advance and
this is totally just an example we're
gonna say obviously and you can have the
broadcast rights but I'm retaining
everything else I want the rights to go
someplace else to distribute this
digitally I want the ability to monetize
this elsewhere because you're not giving
me enough money to recoup my expenses
pay back my investors etc you both have
a chapter in the book copywriting
clearance that reads advertising that
sells your film can also kill your film
do tell well that's part of the fair use
chapter and the a lot of filmmakers
think great it's fair use and then they
send the film off to have a trailer made
and some of that material that was fair
use in the film will show up in the
trailer that isn't necessarily true the
the trailer has to be evaluated on its
own to decide whether the material is
fair use as it appears in the trailer
what was it what was the one you worked
on with Mark Ruffalo playing a sex
addict that was called thank you for
sharing okay yeah that was called thank
you for sharing and in that film it was
a little different fair use issue it was
it was a narrative film and Mark Ruffalo
was walking down the street and as he's
walking on the street they capture
purposefully images of Victoria's Secret
models I mean
you know jeans at with a very sexy woman
on it and all these things and they
wanted to use those in the trailer they
appear in the film and without
permission because they captured them on
the street but in the trailer we had to
review that again to make sure that the
use of the trailer was fair use and we
determined it was after many
conversations and getting together and
making sure we were all comfortable with
it and because there was a comment on
those you know it was explanation of
what the film is about what this guy's
addiction was and how it gets fed by
billboards and media all over the place
it's like oh my god how do you not think
about sex when you're bombarded with
these images and so we determined that
was okay and that was okay to use them
in them in the trailer so not only does
the actual film all ninety minutes or
whatever have to pass the fair use sort
of litmus test but then also the trailer
is held up too it has a different
standard it is a different standard and
also the moat we don't get a lot of
calls or complaints in this office but
most of them come from trailers or
teasers that people put up on a
Kickstarter campaign that have not been
cleared by ads it reaches more eyeballs
and so those trailers and the teasers
etc that are online more people see them
and there's just a higher risk that
someone's going to view it and then be
upset about the use and so often it
comes to our office and they're like oh
we got this webOS letter and then we
find out it from a trailer that we never
even saw we're like oh we wish you would
have shown that to us you know so we
could have at least rendered an opinion
made sure you had insurance in place and
then we're just having such a stronger
bargaining position when that's the case
let's say a screenwriter is working on a
based on a true story
type screenplay and it's either based on
a real person or a real historical event
so if this real person
let's say is still living does the
screenwriter need release forms from
this real person this is the question we
get asked all the time and I guess the
first the first answer to that is
legally no you do not need to get those
rights there are a whole host of good
reasons to
and get what we call life rights or even
a release from that person but legally
we all have a right under the First
Amendment to tell a truthful story so if
that story is truthful which if you
don't have the rights in that person we
have to make extra special care to make
sure that it is you don't need any
rights in that individual and if you
think about books how many books there
are and probably every president of the
United States the president doesn't
necessarily authorize every single one
of those books he authorizes one that
has the best picture of him on the front
but the other ones are written because
we will have a First Amendment right to
write those stories based on information
that's in the public so the legal answer
is no and then well why get them and
there's a whole lot of good reasons one
is to reduce liability you know just
because the law is on your side doesn't
mean people won't get upset about
something or think that they should have
gotten their rights acquired and so a
liability issue a delivery issue even if
you plan on delivering this to a big
studio they like to see those types of
agreements in place again because of the
risk and also you might want to have
access to that person they might have
journals and pictures and access to
other people that you want to interview
or conduct research with and they can
provide that access so it's there's a
lot of good reasons to get life rights
but legally you don't need to so let's
suppose though I change the name and
some of the characteristics would that
make it safer for me or again still no
do the journalism do do a do the
research and create an accurate
portrayal you're allowed some dramatic
flexibility but we have to work with a
screen writer on that and I gave you in
another answer the example of welcome to
New York where it was about Dominique
strauss-kahn there are two arguments
between mr. and mrs. Kahn that are
totally made-up nobody was there except
them and we weren't able to talk to them
but the scenes were reasonable
inferences from everything we did know
so some there's some flexibility even on
that but they so often people think oh
I'll change the name and that'll fix it
the issue is is the film of our
concerning a certain person and very
often
my favorite example is we had a film in
about Michael Jackson's alleged
proclivity for little boys and the the
there was one chauffeur in in the film
throughout the film and I said to the
filmmaker is this man still alive oh no
we changed his name and we and I said
but it's the same chauffeur oh yes
Michael Jackson always used the same
chauffeur when he had boys in the car I
said so what good is it to change the
name well we we changed the ethnicity
and we changed his name yeah but there
was only one driver that's the guy you
could make them a Martian and it would
be this man so you have to be very
careful about the notion of I'll make a
few changes and it'll be okay I don't
know where that came from as long as the
person is still recognizable so
recognizable so you know you you see
films all the time and they call a
person I don't know jack instead of John
Wow look at that now you'll never know
it was really John and if a person does
then legally you can still be on the
hook suppose I live with my college
roommate we have a script idea and we
are both writing it and we've completed
this amazing 100 page script we're going
to shop it around
we're friends so there's nothing to
worry about right that's its and this is
so common we I hate to say it but once
or twice a year every year the problem
comes in because it doesn't it doesn't
happen until one of two things either
you can't sell it so one wants to change
it dramatically the other one doesn't
or you get an offer one wants to take it
one doesn't it's that point in time and
then you don't have an agreement what do
we do who gets to decide it's a mess
there are there's an easy collaboration
agreement with comments and the way the
book is set up there's an email address
where you just type it in and you'll get
a clean copy word word version
downloadable that you can change and use
and then you just follow the book along
with how to use it because this this
book when it talks about contracts has a
lot of instructional boxes that tell you
how to use the contracts that are in the
book at what point am I doing this early
very very when you guys are still
friends and me together and loving each
other and loving the script on you know
we see it all the time and people have
interesting memories bad memories
different memories of what the agreement
was who created the storyline who was
the first person to come up with this
idea and we could we have so many
outlandish things that come in the
office I had a guy who came in here one
time and he insisted that he created the
storyline and wasn't the writer he
worked with a friend who actually had
the experience in writing but he
basically created the entire story and
the other guy came in and said
absolutely not this was totally my thing
he came up with a little bit of an idea
I expanded it I wrote the script he gave
me a few notes that weren't even helpful
I mean the stories were night and day
and so have they in nish and they ended
up actually just scrapping the project
it was a sin
burnt a script they said forget it we're
not gonna move forward with each other
and there's there's no way we're gonna
reconcile this and have they just at the
beginning put together something simple
I sent me a simple collaboration
agreement or something simple even by
email saying you know I came up with
this you came up with this we're gonna
work together we're gonna be owners on
this fifty-fifty since I had the
experience more as a producer I'm gonna
shop this and I'll come to you with any
sort of deals and we'll make sure that
we're both okay with it you know
something very simple just that outlines
what will happen in success and what
will happen if one of us wants to move
on
what if somebody gets a full-time job
and they can't work on the script
anymore so just to lay out those
contingencies even in a simple way is so
important and from another practical
perspective if the film does get sold or
somebody's interested in it they don't
want to deal with the drama between the
two writers they want that resolved
whose face whose name is first you know
how all of that kind of stuff they
wanted settled otherwise they'd move on
to the next project because there are a
lot of scripts out there so even a
simple email exchange in the initial
beginning of forming the story idea
would have been satisfactory yeah
helpful you know how they it's sometimes
it might have been completely conclusive
like this is the deal in other
circumstances that you might say well
there's seven other email strings and
look what we said over here you know so
there certainly could be that but it's
always helpful to have at least
something in writing a lot of people
avoid it because they want to avoid some
court of conflict in it when people say
that to me I said oh my gosh okay you're
gonna avoid a conflict now to crews but
you're going to face it someday so so
you don't want to put all the prize the
time and effort into writing a script
and then not know what you're gonna do
with it decide that now decide it when
you can say oh okay that's the way you
want to okay I guess I don't want to
write a script with you because that's a
big commitment sure people are making
these commitments all the time without
an understanding of how's it going to
play out cuz not every script gets
immediately sold for a million bucks and
made into a film
wins an Academy Award they're actually
scripts written that that doesn't happen
to you learn a new thing every day yes
how does one have the talk then with
with a friend roommate whatever we're
the lab raters imagine how does whatever
yeah how do you do it in a
non-threatening way that's not like oh
hey my lawyer asked me to send this to
you and say how does someone do it in a
very sort of easygoing way eventually
bringing out some type of contract but
that's not the first words out of your
mouth is before we actually start
writing okay comma comma dot dot dot
okay maybe we should talk about the
business side of our relationship period
next sentence whose name will go first
on the script is one that's one issue
that should be so are we going to be
50/50 owners just putting the questions
there yeah and I know understand this is
uncomfortable especially when you're
working with friends to talk about those
things but it's so important and you can
say I just read this book clearance and
copyright and it suggested that we have
this conversation now I think it can be
done in a way because it's beneficial
for both parties you know you're not
saying let's have this conversation
because I'm trying to protect my
interest it's like let's have this
conversation because in the event we're
lucky enough for someone want to buy
this we need to have all these things
worked out so let's just work it out now
you know so if someone's response to
that which I've here this oh I'm totally
cool I'm so easygoing don't even worry
about it
but yeah dot dot dot then you would
interject with that sounds great so am i
but let's just get this right that's
right yeah he's just having that
conversation they can be a little bit
difficult but one that will be so much
more difficult and can potentially ruin
your project down the road if you wait
yeah and you know if it turns out that
the two of you have a very different
idea like oh yeah we're write it
together alone at 5050 but I get to make
all the decisions about how it's
exploited
Oh can we talk about that no that's a
that's an absolutely okay maybe I don't
want to write this script yeah and and
then your your plate your life is open
for some other project that where the
working relationship is better and that
is a good point if you can't have that
conversation with the person you're
writing a script with maybe you
shouldn't be writing that script with
that person